we talked about tingled sorry blondie I
don't do backstory at this point is not
sequel but we are good we are doing a TV
show that's right Zachary Levi is set to
reprise his role as Finn for the tango
TV series Mandy Moore is also back as
Rapunzel it's 26 episodes a season for
three seasons this series basically
takes place between the end of tangled
and before they end up getting married
and like whatever those adventures and
everything worse
be honest do you feel like frozen stole
your guys's thunder a little bit Zach
told me he wishes everyone success but
didn't MIT that Disney's John Lasseter
swore off any more fairy tale movies
after tangled he said alright guys this
is it this is the last one and then he
made tangled and we did really well and
it was enough to buoy that for them to
even go and make processing right so I
will say you're welcome
this isn't frozen people you're welcome
you are welcome so Zach's back for
tingle but is a revival of Chuck a
possibility no well that's what I'd like
to do I ever since even before we
wrapped the show I wanted to I always
thought it'd be really fun to go and do
like annual or semiannual Chuck movies
you know just to get the band back
together for a month or two or whatever
but getting everybody back together to
bring the series back together would be
difficult I mean making a television
series is a lot more involved in motion
and making a movie